I'm terrible at
talking you would think I wouldn't be
but
I I get up there in in front of the
podium and my my my brain just just goes
that's mine that's hyperlock yeah
totally toally I knew I was here for a
reason but
was
okay I'm sorry about my delay uh route
2029 was
uh we're going at a crawl turtle turtle
speed all right first up
1081 relative insurance payments to
ambulance
providers so I think I've done this
build
before
uh so um I guess first of all who's
have you had your nice little list
yesterday do we
okay okay and repres said gives your on
I am
yeah okay so the issue comes down to um
is that the insurance companies are
paying
the the patient rather than the
Insurance the ambulance companies and
the ambulance companies are
saying that well you know insurance
companies pay other providers that are
not necessarily in their networks why
are they picking on them and the upshot
being that the and I guess you know we
have if we understand the role of manage
care and the invention of Managed Care
was that the whole point is that that uh
they would insurance companies would
have
contracts with
providers and we dealt with the problem
obviously when it came
to um
anesthesiologists and theologists and
other other ones when it comes to the
hospital but that the hospital was in
the mix there in this case this is just
an ambulance um on its own um obviously
ambulances are very unique industry in
the sense that that they're they they're
247 but it any you know but they're
they're they're sitting around waiting
to get a call you know they're they're
not it's not like they get guaranteed
clients in business and that I assume
that's the reason why they don't sign
contracts uh because they don't get
enough money
for not doing any business so I guess
let's I'll hear from the subcommittees
and how how you guys feel about this
bill
you
want
so Vincent's on this one too how did he
get yeah how did Vincent get on two of
sense I up for vinc I know but how dides
he get on I thought he yesterday he was
on liquor yesterday and then how did he
get me into didn't I switch him around
you guys all made the news
yesterday you guys all made the news
yesterday
see
am
switch the one I show okay
right because I made that switch
between was going to we took he wanted
here
all right so
I so we well I guess I'll have to
replace beu because he's not here right
now mean if we're if we're going to end
up you know being 44 then obviously
we're not going to want to go forward
with this bill but I don't know how
everybody feels about it yeah obviously
just for the record the committee has
killed this bill multiple years and
simply because um they you know this is
contractual issue it's about getting a
contract so represent I thought that we
um so the so the question I have is it's
kind of like related to that if they if
the ambulances get the money does that
imply that they cannot also
Bill the insured
person because the money that they got
from for the from the insurance company
didn't cover even half of what it
actually cost to do it right is there a
a limit itation there as a result of
that ter from them doing the balance
billing right okay uh someone want to
respond to that
question you would say okay yes you can
always balance bill right so that was
the one difference about this bill this
piece of legislation undiff from what we
did with the with those other
professions was that balance billing is
still in here that the only difference
being is that they want the check the
check to get mailed to them directly
rather than going through the patient
and I I guess I'll tell a little story
on this one so um one of my employees a
deer attacked it his truck and the
insurance company sent me the check well
the check is clearly way too low for
what it's going to cost to repair it and
they said well you just hold on to that
check and then and then uh give it to
the whoever your auto body shop is and
then then but my deathly fear is if I
cast that check then I'm accepting that
payment and so it's uh kind of an
awkward situation so I would assume in
the same thing happens with these
patients that that if they they they get
that check in the mail they would know
not to cash it they would know to turn
it over because they certainly wouldn't
want to be in in a Jeopardy situation so
representative
Gibbs thank you um I've been in this
situation several times and the problem
was never one that the insurance company
didn't pay enough for the ambulance
company to accept it the problem was
simply that they said they sent it to me
and then um I had to figure out where to
send it and there was one instance when
the company changed ownership in between
when they had um taken me to the
hospital and when I sent them the check
so I sent the check to the wrong place
and they sent it back to me it was in
credible complication and for that
reason uh I strongly support this
bill okay um chairman my my
understanding is that the people were
getting the check and cashing it and
keeping the money and that's why the
insurance companies wanted to it to go
directly to the ambulances and for that
reason I would support this bill as well
no the insurance companies don't want to
go directly to the ambulance
right say that again
but okay so why you kind of have to come
up and speak to the microphone the
ambulan that directly and the patient
also and identif for the record my name
is Michelle heat and I'm the health and
polic health law and policy legal
council at the insurance department and
this issue has a very long and sorted
pth as representative hunt alluded to um
it's been a problem for many years this
issue of balance billing where a outof
network ambulance respond responds to
emergency situation provides the
transport and then the person's
insurance gets built because that
ambulance provider is out of network
there is no contractual relationship
between the insurer and the ambulance
provider the insurer pays what they
would consider to be a reasonable rate
for those services and because there's
no contractual
relationship between the parties they
send it to the person they have the
contract with with which is the
patient the reason um there is this
provision in law that says you can
provide it directly to the provider or
the patient is if it's in network you're
going to send it to the provider because
you have a contract with them if it's
out of network you send it to the
patient because the patient is the one
ultimately liable for these services
that were out of network and what's
going to happen is the ambulance
provider is going to build the patient
for the services they rendered the
patient is supposed to use that check
they got from the insurance department
to pay the provider now this is just one
aspect of the issue um currently ground
ambulance is the only service that in
emergency situations you can still
balance Bill the patient so if the
provider doesn't feel like the insurance
compan is paying enough for their
services they can then Bill the patient
for the amount that the insurer did not
cover that is the bigger issue that
still needs to be addressed here this
bill the way it's written right now is
only making it so that the provider will
receive payment directly from the
insurer that they do not have a
contractual relationship with um over
the summer and fall the insurance
department recognizing that that's is
still a major issue for consumers and a
major issue in the insurance industry we
um convened a state colder group
together to try to address some of these
issues and if you'll give me a second I
can give you a quick recap of what we
talked about in that so for this work
group we were specific specifically
focused on the role of commercial health
insurance when considering the overall
funding of ambulance services we want to
address the problem of surprise billing
the balance billing to the patient as
well as the problem of establishing a
more rational stable Equitable funding
mechanism for ambulance services and the
role of commercial Health insurers in
that system we also were looking at the
problem of the inefficiencies in the
current system and an opportunity to
improve Service delivery models everyone
agreed that ambulance providers are
vital to emergency responsing
communities and an integral part of the
Healthcare System we were able to
identify some common ground on a number
of issues there was agreement that
ambulance providers need adequate
funding to ensure they can provide
necessary Services when called upon
there was also agreement that the
current emergency transport system is
inefficient and that a better that
better delivery models ought to be
available although there's very little
support for the idea of um continuing
surprise ambulance building
ambulance providers are generally
loathed to tackle that issue in
isolation without also solving the
overall problem of how best to Fund
emergency
services the overarching policy issue
that prevents stakeholders from reaching
any further consensus is whether the
funding of these Services where the
funding of for these Services should
come from some argue that communities
should decide what emergency services
will be available in their community and
that is appropriate for communities to
cover any funding gaps with public funds
others argue that commercial insurance
Market should be paying an amount
adequate to cover the cost of providing
services that are not covered by
Medicare and Medicaid it is important to
note that only about 20% of all
transports involve commercially insured
patients if commercial insurers are
required to pay significantly higher
fees to compensate for other payers like
Medicare and Medicaid not paying enough
then the cost of funding these Emergency
Services gets shifted to Consumers
purchasing commercial
insurance this philosophical divide
regarding who should be responsible for
funding emergency services in
communities is the major obstacle that
prevents stakeholders from working out
any further details about how to address
this important issue so that's a very
broad overview of that this issue is a
lot more complex than direct pay and
this bill is only meant to address that
one little issue and is not going to
address any of the other issues related
to this so
for those of us who have been in the
room with this issue over the years your
arm down for a
second the issue was always originally
balance
billing people wanted to stop the
B the problem would be is if the check
goes directly to the
ambulance and then the ambulance company
bills the patient for the balance
billing the patient will say said no you
got
paid you're all
set so the simple compromise okay
because originally we had had it had to
be paid
direct issue was always balance
billing the compromise that we
originally put in the statute was that
it could
May well the simple answer would be is
that if the insurance company I mean if
the ambulance company wants to check
directly they can't balance
bill that would be the
compromise I
get I know I know I just threw threw the
bomb on the floor and I want everybody
to absorb what I just said okay now
represent of Gibs thank you yes I do
recall that we uh discussed this during
the hearing um and certainly the issue
of balance billing is an issue um but as
I tried to explain earlier
balance billing aside the current system
is harmful not only to the providers
which is what we've mostly been
discussing it's harmful to the patients
because the patients are put in this
incredible complication that is seems to
me to be completely
unnecessary and that's why I I really
think this this bill is necessary do you
understand what I just said I do okay so
the patient's not going to be
misunderstanding and saying is why are
you balance billing me if you've already
been
paid the it this could be in the
statement couldn't
it when the balance billing comes in the
the ambulance company has to say yes we
were PID we did receive x amount of
money but it's not enough and we want
you to pay the difference the cost of
the we got paid paid X the cost of the
service is actually is actually Y and
that's why we want you to pay Z now
that's not my favorite thing I would
rather not have that happen well but you
understand that you're talking about how
this is complicated for the for the
patient so don't you think it would be
the patient would say they would say no
I'm not going to pay you a balance I'm
not going to pay that extra charge
because you've already been
paid Well
it Well that's
is that comom that that problem doesn't
always occur I mean this has happened to
me three or four times and there was
never an issue of the insurance company
paying too little the provider was
always willing to accept the amount
provided by the insurance company the
problem was where do you send the money
that's what I'm saying to you I agree
with this bill if we add a sentence that
there would be no balance billing if the
ambulance company wants the check
directly it doesn't want to go through
the patient
if they want the tech
directly then they can't balance bill
then who is represent spear would
legislators get to speak first but when
when when we had uh when when we had the
hearing we heard uh
testimony that was literally scary to me
yes in conquered where the ambulance is
pretty close to the hospital and people
live close to the hospital that's fine
and you know the balance and you don't
probably don't need balance spilling
maybe I don't know but Upstate where
they're traveling sometimes we we heard
stories of having to go out of state to
get people to a hospital I mean
horrendous
stories I don't know how B how you could
ever cut out balance billing for that
kind of
situation you know so I I cannot go
along with that so represent prelli yeah
thank you I have um a few questions so
would Medicare and Medicaid be
considered contracts so who you know you
know how does medicare and medicaid work
yeah Medicaid pays the provider directly
and I understand that some of the
providers are local municipalities so
does that bring another complication
into the mix and um I get build for out
of network providers all the time so I'm
not really sure why this would be I'm
just trying to figure out I'm not sure
why this particular service would be so
much more egregious than any out of
network provider where I get a bill that
has the balance of what was what the
service was and what the insurance
company paid and what I'm responsible
for so I'm just trying to figure out
those issues and thank you for at least
trying to have the conversation but I
think a lot more work still needs to
happen and I hope you didn't say well we
tried and that's it we're we had a
commission we tried that's we're done I
hope you're continuing
we are open to continuing our work but
the issue's kind of at its stand still
where we have the all the stakeholders
and it's not just two sides it'd be more
like a circle and everyone's on the very
periphery and until they start moving a
little bit closer we're kind of at a
standstill so someone needs to give up
something there needs to be some kind of
negotiation on this issue for us to
continue um to get to your questions yes
it is the same for all outof Network
providers so the provisions in this bill
are not specific to ambulance it's for
all outof Network providers and it's the
same process for anyone as for respect
to billing billing works the same
whether you're your municipality or any
other kind of Provider you would send
the bill to The Entity responsible for
paying and then they pay the bill for
Medicare and Medicaid there are set
rates that are set by both of the
programs currently in New Hampshire um
last year there was legislation passed
that increased funding foric Medicaid So
currently in New Hampshire it's the same
rate being paid for both Medicare and
Medicaid traditionally Medicaid had um
paid about half of what Medicare pays so
right now they're um
equal that payment that's set by those
programs is payment in full and if the
person is covered by those programs the
providers are not allowed to balance
situations and the other out of network
why don't you stay
there so any other out of I'm trying to
figure out what's the difference between
this bill and any other out of the
example I'll give is when you go to an
out of network doctor physician whatever
you don't leave without
paying right usually you don't get you
get a you I get a bill okay so they let
you out the door without because usually
I whenever I've been to an out of
network there's some typ of down they're
expecting payment a certain percentage
and then I get a bill for the rest did
right but at usually like you say when I
when I go to convenient MD or you know
some I they're going to charge me right
up
front well I'm just saying any any yeah
normally when you're going out a network
they're probably different every they're
charging you before you before you go
home a certain percentage and then the
balance and that's what the issue is is
that they they don't carry a credit card
machine in the ambulance no I can't
understand so ever plan is a little bit
different some plans do cover out of
network services and that there could be
cost sharing associated with it most um
manage care plans exclude out of network
unless it's an emergency situation or um
sometimes Urgent Care could be included
in that the procedure for it is the same
though that the patient will be sent a
bill from that out of network provider
because the out of network provider
whether they're an ambulance a doctor or
a facility does does not have a
contractual relationship with the
insurer the patient then is responsible
for submitting it to the insurance if
you have any kind of out of network
benefit um if you don't have an out of
network benefit then you're likely going
to have to pay that full amount and the
patient is the one responsible for it
because it's excluded usually from your
policy that it's not going to be covered
but some policies do cover out of
policy okay other questions yes
represent BR um this isn't a question
it's a would you believe I mean I just
share representative porcelli's uh
frustration that you know we seem to
just and I I was on that commission for
one day um and then stepped off um I I
feel frustrated that we're kind of
saying oh well there's nothing we can do
and I don't know what the answer is
either but it's very
frustrating representative Gibbs thank
you uh this is also a comment it was
just said that this bill refers to all
out ofet Network providers but I have it
here right in front of me um and just
looked at it again it refers
specifically to ambulance providers not
all out of network providers she when
she says all it's not the bill it is
that that is the underlying statute that
does say that out of if you're out of
network right but this bill Deals Only
with ambulances that's correct you're
choosing just one industry right
now so anybody
else
okay okay we'll let the
so what's the difference if the patient
gets the
check then sends it in and we balance
build them that way they still got a a
chunk of money whether it went directly
to the am ambulance or whether it came
through the patient to the ambulance
we're still going to balance billum they
still know what's going to happen if you
really want to make balance billing go
away pay the whole bill have the
insurance companies pay the whole bill
that we're charging them I still can't
really wrap my head around how an
insurance company gets to say now you
ask for 500 but we feel like we're only
going to pay you 300 cuz I know if my
oil company showed up put $500 of oil in
my tank and I said I don't really think
the oil's worth 500 I'm only going to
pay you 300 they're either going to come
and suck the oil out or send me to jail
so I still don't have can't figure out
how they get away with that because I
call that theft but that's just me
so they keep trying to use this to get
us in network we can't come in the
network we can't afford to be in their
Network we won't survive and then when
you down
911 nobody's coming or if they are
they're coming from a long way away so
that's the decision I guess that you
guys have to make whether we're coming
or not right but you're saying what's
the difference of where the who the
check gets mailed to so the question is
what's wrong with the system
now they spend it and they don't pay the
ambulance they being the patient correct
so so so that you're you're thinking
that if you get the check ahead of time
they won't they won't spend your that
what the back build the B balance
billing we also run into that we get
calls all the time I got this what do I
do with it I don't know what where to
send this where's the address where do
where do I mail it so if anything it's
helping the patient es especially you
know just been through traumatic stuff
where do I send the bill where do I send
that check
right so it just makes it easier on the
patient How about if um when you deliver
that patient to wherever they're going
on you hand them a piece of paper right
then and there and said they can sign
off to have the bill the the check sent
directly to them direct to another way
have have we do do they have that waiver
now we do and they still send it to the
patient so they ignore the inter come
ignore that name okay well maybe that
compromise kind of all compromised out
no
no the compromise when you get we've
already been dealing with this issue how
many times how many times have you put
this bill in this is my first okay how
many times have you come into this
committee and supported the legislation
right couple of times couple why and
that's the question why do I have to
keep coming back this is pretty
straightforward okay representative
burrow would it be helpful if when the
check comes there's a big big uh piece
of paper and bold letters that says this
isn't yours you need to send it to the
ambulance company yeah I think the
insurance company's going to do that no
no no no no no that you they're not
telling you the truth the truth is you
build you let the customer the patient
know you have in their mailbox within a
week of the billing that they are going
that they're going to be receiving the
check you let them know this happening
the problem is evidently for
representative Gibbs she needs to each
time it happens to call up and say I
don't understand your letter that says
by the way I'm going to balance bill you
based upon whatever you end up sending
whatever that check is Mr chairman I
received no such notice and by the way
the so no Ambulance Company ever mailed
you a notice that you might never and
I'm talking three or four what is wrong
with you ambulance companies Mr chairman
may I
continue thank you um just in reference
to conquered I once had an ambulance
take me a quarter mile and the bill was
almost
$1,000 and again there was 900 and
something paid to me by the insurance
company and by the way in reference to
signing a piece of paper when they get
you to the hospital the last time I was
taken to the hospital was because I woke
up at 3:00 in the morning in
excruciating pain and I can assure
everyone that at that point I was not in
any shape to understand anything that I
might be asked to sign so I I I don't
think that that is really the the
solution I can't believe you were
charged of
$1,000 in the city of conquered uh I
I've been charged $1,000 in the city of
conquered several times the worst one
was when it was a quarter mile because I
was in my doctor's office um I had gone
to my doctor's office due to repeated
indigestion I'm sorry to make a long
story of this okay well here here's the
question real quick was it the City
ambulance or was it the the uh a private
Ambulance Company well that was that was
the change it changed from the city
ambulance to the private ambulance
company and both times they charge you a
thousand well they've charged me almost
a thousand every single time okay but
that quarter mile I was in my doctor's
office my doctor's office was a quarter
mile
from the hospital my doctor gave me a
test and she said I think you're having
a heart attack and I said okay I'll go
with the hospital and taxi she said you
can't go in a taxi you have to go in an
ambulance we calling an ambulance for me
so they called an ambulance the
ambulance took me a quarter mile I
wasn't feeling that bad I could have
walked uh but I got a bill for almost
$1,000 I am not exaggerating got and
again I went through this craziness and
the current system is har harmful to the
patient okay representative
taxon before I get into my actual
testimony I would like to say to
representative Gibbs if there is anyone
in this room who could walk a quarter of
a mile to a hospital while having a
heart attack I'm sure it would be
you I the thing of it was I was not
having a heart attack my doctor Mis
misunderstood something and I was fine I
was perfectly fine but the doctor said
you have to go to the hospital well
should that happen I'm sure you'll make
it um but I want to I have to put on my
I have to put on my selectman's hat in
the two towns that I represent I'm a
selectman in the town of
Troy and unfortunately in New Hampshire
when you become a selectman you learn
things that you never wanted to know and
the one of the big challenges that we
had is our Ambulance
Service and so the issue as a business
owner I look at the billing and say well
why don't you guys just send a bill and
then the answer we get back from the
ambulance service is what's going on
here they send the check to the patient
who spends it or when we when we send
them a bill they say they don't have it
anymore when you when you live in a
rural area when you live with people I
mean is there something murkier than
medical bill I can't imagine what that
would
be so I have to say that well I would
like to think that people would be
reasonable and say oh this is the check
for $900 from my insurance company
that's supposed to pay for my $1,000
ambulance ride the reality in the world
is the patient gets a check for a th
from 900 bucks from the insurance
company and that immediately goes to
whatever they want to spend their $900
on as a selectman as in a town that now
has we have a joint quasi
volunteer between
quasi joint operation in Troy and Fitz
William for the operations of our
ambulances which has been very
successful and we have not had to sign
on with chesher County's very
expensive
unfunded uh ambulance program
but we still have the issue of billing
and in our case it's cheaper for the
taxpayers of the two towns to subsidize
the short which is largely made up by
the the short is the Billings that we
don't get the money back on because they
sent the checks to the the
patients I'm I don't want to quote our
billing our what we actually our
collections rate because I understand it
has
improved and the other thing that I
think you have have to consider is Mo
not over here in the big side of the
state but when you get into the rural
part of the state I'm sure up in Coos
County it's the same and I know what it
is in Cheshire county these are Quasi
volunteer projects operations it's Town
people and they don't want to be bill
collectors they don't want to Hound
their friends and neighbors who just had
a heart attack for a $400 check and when
you talk to the guys that run the
ambulance squads they'll tell you that's
it's like well yeah we know they got the
money and we know they owe it to us but
now I have to be a bill collector and
that's not what they signed on for they
want to save lives not collect
bills and you know I we as Selectmen we
have to deal with that we ultimately get
to be the bill
collectors
but so for those all of those wonderful
reasons on my part I really have to say
this is is a this is a big problem in
small towns the smaller the ambulance
service the bigger a problem this is and
I would have to support the bill to send
the checks directly to the ambulance
people and and I don't see why you can't
bill the patient for the deficiency if
the Bill's
$1,000 and the $900 check goes directly
to the ambulance Squad they can bill for
$100 and quite frankly if the people
can't pay it in all of the ambulance I'm
aware of they're going to write it off
anyway so the the balance billing is is
going to be mute because if you mail the
check directly to the ambulance the
patient won't pay the balance billing
anyways corre and so they're they're
still out the money so at least they're
getting the check but they're still
getting more money than they're the the
40% of the money that they're getting
now okay representative M uh thank you
Mr chairman just again I do think that
that sending the the check to the to the
person is dumb we don't do that in other
types of medical care I don't go in and
have an operation for a knee replacement
and and and get a $10,000 check uh it's
paid directly and and there may be a
co-payment and then I pay that so I
don't see why this should be any
different I I think the bill makes sense
as our person from the insurance
department said it's it's not covering
the whole thing because there a lot of
different problems but I think it's a
step of the in the right direction it'll
get part of it covered so I I I support
this wholeheartedly thank you right well
representa M just pointed out to me that
the the problem is that the bank is
cashing the check in the first place
because the check does say payable to
the ambulance company and and but that
they're still cashing it that's no no
it's required by Statute in the current
law the ambulance it's supposed to say
the insurer and the ambulance service
provider so the for the patient to say
they don't know who why that other name
is on the
check the ones I got were payable to
Merill Gibbs how long ago was that a
couple years ago okay because this is
law this law has been on a book how long
we've had with the last time we did this
where we put in the uh the ambulance
come yeah I don't think they're coming
that way they're not coming that way so
you're saying they're violating the law
shocker isn't
violation I'll try and get you a cheuck
violation then we'll have to give it to
the ambulance service if it's
[Laughter]
true right uh representative Peli then
representative MCU so um first of all
thank you for your Ambulance Service we
I think we all appreciate especially the
volunteer um services that we have when
we call 911 we definitely appreciate
someone coming and helping but I wanted
to understand why is it so difficult to
ensure why is it so difficult to sign a
contract with the insurance companies
you mentioned that it's too expensive
can you expound on that correct and then
is there a difference between private
ambulance and municipalities with the
contracts and then finally would uh
municipalities pay the difference if the
um Pro if the uh patient cannot
pay okay let me see if I can get all
three of those
so
um yeah no what was the first
one about you mentioned that it's too
difficult to sign so so if we take what
they offer cuz usually it's not just
$100 it's usually about mean signing a
contract but you mention it's too
complicated to sign contracts with
they're just not getting enough they're
not getting enough so if we sign the
contract we take what they give us and
Bill not because we want
to right it's a federal law so we we
can't get around that that it's it's the
law and and yes we lose money on those
patients right if you notice there's a
lot of doctors that don't take Medicare
and Medicare patients anymore and that's
why because they lose money right so we
don't sign the contract because we don't
want to lose money again it's bad enough
we're losing it with the feds so we
can't bellance bill if we take that
contract that's why we don't take that
contract and you're next one next
question was yes I just I wanted to
understand so if the if the patient
cannot pay and it's a municipal so if
the patient does go back to the town how
does that work and and I can only tell
so if that patient has gotten has
received the
check has cashed the check hasn't sent
us the money but we know they receive
the
check we
will send them a bill three or four
times and and then maybe put them into
collections if they did not get a check
or they sent us a check and we send them
the balance Bill we will Bill them three
times and then the town writes it
off it's similar to what you're doing
with Medicaid or Medicare correct
so but we're trying to survive right and
and the difference between a private
ambulance in a
municipality if the private ambulance is
not doing emergency contracts and just
doing transfer work from One hospital to
the other the nurseing home to there
right those are pretty much scheduled
calls uh they know they're going to be
busy all day so even at that low rate
they're making up in
volume what we can't make up in volume
right so they do better in their volume
right where we sit around ready not just
sitting around but you know we're
working and ready to
respond but if we don't
get four five six seven calls that day
we're not making the volume right we may
only get one call that day and you've
paid a crew of two minimum to be 24
hours and now we have to
pay pretty substantial especially like
during the a lot of departments hire
people during the day
because the the volunteers of old aren't
here
anymore right they're they're working
they may not be able to work in town
anymore they have to leave town so
they're not available for calls looks
like somebody had a early morning
call
no oh okay uh but so we end up having to
pay people now
because like I know in the town of eping
the people that would take these
volunteer jobs can't afford to live in
town anymore so we end up having to pay
pretty much
247 so that's what we're trying to do
just staylo represent M thank you Mr
chairman so a few thoughts on this for
the committee um EMS has been my career
for a long time some of you already know
that private public volunteer whatever
and and the issue here is helping these
EMS Services be sustainable so they're
available for the most number of people
in the most solvent fashion and you know
insurance companies have had a chance to
do the right thing for a long time and
some do and some services are able to
sign a contract but some aren't and many
patients like representative Gibbs who
are very capable of getting themselves
to the hospital may feel compelled to
utilize those services and then get
stuck with the bill um point of fact is
you always have the ability to sign off
or sign a refusal as we call it you know
the vernacular is is a refusal of
services but you very well maybe
pressured by your PCP or the providers
themselves to say well you know we're
not responsible for what happened
happens you could die in five minutes or
I mean you get the idea so a lot of
patients don't sign that refusal and of
course in that type of Life circumstance
don't read the fine print that says you
know where you sign consent to be
transported which I assure you that you
do like it has to be in every EMS run
sheet it's got to go into our state
system you've got to sign or it's
documented why you didn't sign like
you're unconscious or whatever and if
you're unconscious it's implied consent
so you're taken right so but you have to
give consent to transfer to transport
and when you do that you are absolutely
on the run sheet signing consent to be
buildt right similar to when I call um
maybe it's a bad analogy but it's close
if I call Portland Glass and say will
you remember we did the the windshield
bill bill here um and uh you know I call
Portland Glass and say you replace my
windshield they give me well Geico gave
me the option of sending the check to me
or sending it to my dealer well I didn't
want to have to handle that money didn't
know exactly what it was going to cost I
told Geico send it to the dealer as it
turns out they didn't they actually sent
it to me and the dealer G and said
where's our 3,000 bucks um and of course
I hadn't cashed it it was made out to
two parties I just signed it over and
gave it to them that doesn't always
happen um as representative PR has said
and he and I have been in the the EMS
service for about this well I've been 33
years you probably got a few years on me
couple so we see both sides of this
issue and I think now since 80 70 80% I
don't know the current number of EMS is
are provided by Volunteers in the
country and in our state now some of the
largest call volume areas in In fairness
right so if you can look at that 70 80%
number two ways the number of calls done
by volunteers and the number of Staff
right so some of the busier cities like
Manchester Nashville conquered some
others are staffed by full-time folks
that have medical billing as part of
their service and they can go do the
collection plenty of towns just like
representative Faxton said don't want to
harass their neighbors they don't want
the town clerk to be in the billing
collections so they employ a billing or
collections which then takes a cut right
and that that makes makes it a less
valuable proposition so frankly we ought
to pass this bill right and I'm I'm not
always on this side of this type of
thing representative hunt knows that
maybe that's why he kept looking to the
right and didn't want to call on
me
but anyhow they all had something to
share anyways I think we ought to pass
it for those what we're GNA do is uh
we're not going to p take any vote right
now um when I read the bill um and it
just CR crosses out check payable to the
insurer and the ambulance service
provider and then it goes on subject to
the terms and conditions of the policy
plan or contract so since there is no
contract um I guess that means is that
the the insurance company would be up to
saying anything they want to say in the
terms of the policy and wouldn't you be
surprised that next year that they come
back and say something that you didn't
really want them to say in that policy
requirement because they might say in
the policy our policy is not to pay the
ambulance uh you know or something I
would like to see a copy of a check
recent check that did not have the
service provider the ambulance on the
check because I if there is a violation
in the insurance company are violating
the statute that we just passed I
realize this is hasn't been on the books
that long but I would like to know if
there's a violation going on but it
notwithstanding is I think we might need
to look at the the the finished part of
that sentence uh if you really want to
pass this bill okay
so all right thank you very
next
uh oh pandas yeah yeah we're we're ready
we yeah okay right that's what the
right right okay so who would like to
motion
itl yeah uh I will move to itl this bill
okay
okay TL all right moved by
representative pelli second by
representative taxon any discussion on
the motion of in expedient to
legislate see none the clerk or we don't
we don't
right yes anyone wants to speak to the
1081 we're doing no 1081 we're passing
over because right now 1081 even if we
were to pass it we have to uh the Bill's
going to need to be
sub
yeah right
oh so do you have a
replacement for Vincent that's that's
okay M okay okay so uh the motion is in
so we have this is and then I'm I'm
missing Terry so it actually doesn't
so okay so so at this point we'll just
cross that just have them pair each
other okay all right so that means it's
um uh pelli migu
hunt and Cal brro Gibbs and Burrows okay
all those in favor of inexpedient to
legislate raise your raise your hands
okay one two three four five
it I'm I'm I'm pairing you Chris with
with Terry who's your seatmate who's not
here all right
okay all right next one 12:36 relative
to repealing the commission on the
status of health coverage markets for
individuals and small employers oh I
bill
okay
okay so this is a commission that never
met and um it's its mission is sort of
uh Gone
by so um I I'll mov in exped to
legislate
itl so anybody want to Second my motion
for
me okay yeah 1236 you going OTP that
no itl oh excuse me oh oh that's right
that's right I want to pass it I'm sorry
yes OTP excuse me a to pass I don't know
thinking okay right I forgot the key
word repeal
it okay you just like to kill bills any
discussion get Bill even your own I just
can't I can't help
myself okay is that any more more
discussion on um ought to pass on
12:36 seeing none all those in favor
raise your hand 1 2 3 four five six okay
right
okay
right okay Department insurance
department is is this one that needs to
be reviewed it would be need to be rev
1296 do uh review and find out what the
under I'm sorry what's the question yeah
about uh well we have to do uh an impact
financial review a fiscal note yes we
are in the process of uh we had
initially submitted a fiscal note for
1296 um but in preparing for today we
realized that there was a mistake in it
so we're in the process of updating that
that fiscal note um the issue with this
bill is it's trying to mandate
um well it it's requiring the coverage
of Diagnostic and supplemental breast
examinations without cost sharing so
under the current system preventative
Services the just to be clear these are
all covered Services right but
preventative ones are with no cost
sharing currently you do have there is
some cost sharing that is allowed for um
the diagnostic and supplemental right so
to remove that there will be some fiscal
impact and we're in the process of
amending it to um kind of Peg down
exactly what that fiscal impact look
like right because it's Shifting the
cost from the patient to the insurer so
the insur responsibility if it's under
the Medicare Medicare expansion would
that now
require U the state having to pay for
pay no this would not have any defrayal
implications okay so this is just we're
Now using what I call the Murphy Law
which is that which we usually would
hold the bill interim study the bill and
then we would do that financial analysis
but you think you're going to able to do
that in the F the fiscal note yes so
defil would only apply if this was a
service that's being added these are
already covered Services the only thing
that would be changing is that um there
would be no cost sharing for the patient
so um what whatever amount that patient
would normally have to pay under their
policy the insurer is now going to be
resp responsible for so there would be a
slight fiscal impact and we're in the
process of nailing down exactly what
that's going to be but there is um no
issue with defail in this case Okay so
and then the other question is um in my
mind was what can of worms were opening
up in terms of other potential services
like this so when you say these are you
were defining the difference between um
the right now what is free which is the
uh manag manag what was the terms I I
need to write these terms preventative
care so under federal law um
preventative Services as defined by this
Federal um group as preventative that
there's clinical evidence to support
this those Services need to provi be
provided without cost sharing got it all
other services in your medical plan are
typically covered in some way by cost
sharing so it could be subject to
deductible it could have Co insurance
have a code what do you just you just
say cost sharing cost sharing okay cost
sharing so depending on your benefit
design that's how much cost sharing
you'll have to pay so if you're thinking
of the tiered plans and the um the
silver gold Platinum bronze plans the
difference in those plans is your amount
of cost sharing so you may have 30% cost
sharing or 20% cost sharing or 10% cost
sharing depending on what level um metal
level you have so that cost sharing
amount and every plan's different so it
could be a co-pay it could be co-
Insurance um so it's kind of hard to Peg
down an exact number about what this
would impact but yes um to your thought
about how this could kind of this
slippery soap argument these services
are Diagnostic and like all other
diagnostic services they are typically
subject to come some kind of cost
sharing this bill is intending to carve
out these specific services so that
there is no cost sharing so I should
know this but I I I don't what's the
difference between co- insurance and
deductible and co-pay what does co-
insurance mean your deductible is say
you have a $1,000 deductible you're
going to have to pay that $1,000 before
all of your services are going to be
covered right without I know what co-pay
is so the co-pay is you go to the doctor
you're goingon to have a $30 co-pay
that's what what is co- insurance so co-
insurance is if you don't have a co-pay
sometimes there's a co- Insurance it'll
be 10% co- insurance or 20% Co insurance
so so rather than amount it's a
percentage Yeah it's a percentage so if
the contracted we rate is $100 and you
have 20% Co Insurance you're responsible
for $20 okay so I put dollar dollars
over co-pay and percentages over co-
insurance and now I know the difference
okay so the question then is um in terms
of this particular issue was that it
seemed that this one of the part of this
discussion was that all right we get the
the free mamogram you get to get that
you have that now they have they're U
they're not sure there's they're not
they're not getting and so then we're
going to now send you off to get this
more expensive
MRI but that technically could be still
preventative because well I'm just
saying in my mind it still could be
preventative because we're making sure
that what we didn't see or could see
were the the first free one that we now
want to you know drill down and do
better okay so the then would be in in
terms of a comparison to other cancers
okay so if they uh if they uh do uh I
don't know maybe a colonoscopy which is
free and then they say well you know
we're concerned whether you know you're
something else so I don't know where
they get to find other when the thing is
matized and moved around but in other
things where where in terms of cost
sharing one is actually we're trying to
help you cure you you know we're trying
to like go in there and we're going to
start pulling things out you know the
tumors out versus we just we're still
not really sure whether you do have
breast cancer right so in other words if
we were to narrow this bill to that that
one
MRI that is a
followup
from the the mamogram is that possible
could we do it as that to just simply
say that if it is a it's it's only a
followup but then any other Pro you know
if if going forward the decision is to
do that that you know all bets off it's
still the cost sharing but that yeah so
the way it's written now there's nothing
wrong with this language um or if you
want to limit it in some way you do that
as well it's just going to come
down impact is going to be that's right
I'm saying what my fear of this is that
we've opened up the door for all kinds
of other body you know me toos that we
want we too want to get rid of the CER
and and let's face it the whole reason
we have high deductibles is because
people want to have a lower premium so
start when you start getting rid of
deductibles you're you're you know
you're yeah it's all you're messing all
Balancing Act you're messing up the
balance by by start picking it you know
pulling things out so I was just focus
in on the fact that we have this uh you
know we have these two things is
colonoscopy and mammograms that are that
are free and so that and that if if it
was really true if this issue if we just
were focusing in on to ensure that we
really are making the right diagnosis so
that you get one free one yeah I mean
that's an option that would be for the
policy makers to make so now I'll open
up to the committee members and hear
what other people are
thinking yes representative pelli I
guess I have a um general question about
more information we seem to have a lot
of bills related to um requiring
insurance coverage so I'm trying to
figure out you know what is that list
that we already have and then I'm sure
that will be added to every year and
then you know the cost sharing issue so
these are the two areas regardless of
what the health issue is I just see both
lists growing and then at what how do
you determine which one goes on you know
is eligible for the insurance coverage
and the cost sharing and which health
issue is not it gets to be very
complicated such a good question um it
is true and I meant to
have Kristen to one up U the last time I
did it it was Pam smling was still our
committee researcher and uh and she was
maintaining the list for me um I would
say after the Affordable Care Act passed
we've seen a reduction in health
insurance mandates uh because of this uh
requirement that that uh the state might
have to pay for it's a new a new mandate
um uh in this case I would say I was in
the room for almost all 40 of them when
I first got on this committee the only
mandates we had was uh the first one was
uh whether social workers can provide
Mental Health Coverage that was mandated
that shows you how long ago that was um
but yes we I think that's a good idea
I'll get that list for everybody it's
it's an amazing list to see all the
things that over the years the
legislature has dealt with when it comes
to to the
mandates so but yeah representative
Bros
right um I just want to say that I mean
I thought we heard really compelling
testimony from um doctors from patients
um people and other people in the field
about um women not not going to get the
uh follow-up exams because of the cost
because of their families because of
missing work and uh I think that this
one is just too important not to to just
to just pass by and I I I think it's
important that that um well I'm not
passing it by I'm just saying I don't
want to give a a free get out of jail I
mean how many how many MRIs are you want
to give away now if you're saying is
that one of the one of the questions was
that once you had an MRI y then then you
don't get the free mammographies anymore
that was what one of the comments was
you don't get them anymore and that
everyone has to be the the MRI from that
then on out well but you do need
followup once you've been diagnosed I
well that was no that right well okay
but then you're a cancer patient so are
we going to say that every cancer
patient not just this one should be get
free MRIs what do we do when other
patients get followup for cancer I'm
just saying when it comes to cancer I
assume all MRIs I assume they're doing
by MRIs but some of them might be just
ultrasounds I don't
know or or they do to do a biopsy is
surg I mean that's even more money but
I'm sure they get they have to pay for
that but yes but you lose oh I'm sorry
re thank you chairman I'm sorry
um it's Diagnostic Imaging we're talking
about we're talking about surveillance
Imaging that's a term that we use right
when we have somebody with a um an
illness and we're trying to just surveil
it we know they have the cancer or that
they're at risk for it right we demand
that they do certain things the
insurance companies will cover cover
those modalities the problem that we're
having is there's a gap between
affordability here it is in the
insurance company best interest to
address their proper care if we continue
to just ignore their orders or to
continue to believe that these patients
are going to just suck it up and pay for
the diagnostic imaging you're
mistaken what ends up happening is they
end up not going they end up ending in
the ER I end up getting the progress
notes from let me let me just cut you
off so you're saying we should do this
for all cancer patients I'm saying that
we need to allow insurance companies to
make better policies I don't want the
general court to get involved here but
when they're not well we're we're we're
involved that's what this bill is yes is
are we going to say no more deductibles
co-pays for cancer patients no this is
just a no that's today this is
surveillance that's today Ry will be
back next week next year with another
one another cancer patient
this is today today is just this
particular you know breast cancer but um
uh you know prostate cancer you name all
the cancers are out there that I'm sure
they use these MRI machines for right I
think you're not looking at the big
picture here and that is that there are
more and more providers that are trying
to fight insurance companies to get
these things done and they're not
getting done because of that reason
these people are going to die okay I I I
hear you but you are you ready to pay
the insurance premium for every cancer
patient to get all these MRIs for free
when we're avoiding the long-term cost
of emergency visits over and over again
because they've been avoiding it yes
okay representative prelli what I have
in my notes is that once you're uh
diagnosed as a cancer patient then you
are ineligible for the yearly test and
then you have to pay for your test so I
wanted to
understand if I mean I'm I'm not sure
why they why we're in enabling the um
loss of that yearly preventive test now
that you've been diagnosed so should
that still be right well that's where I
was getting into is that if so you get
the one to get the each year and then if
there's other um tests that you would
need that would be subject to your
insurance so but you shouldn't lose your
preventative test you shouldn't lose
because you might not need it you might
let's say let's say this preven just
came back
negative okay that there was it was it
was a shadow it wasn't as bad as it was
but people what we heard from the
testimony was then then they have to be
getting this MRI
forever that they would they wouldn't
they wouldn't get the the once you're
stamped as a cancer patient the way I
have it in my notes is that you're not
eligible for that yearly preventive test
which doesn't make sense right it does
not make sense to does not make sense
spear uh having multiple breast cancer
patients in my family uh the
Reconstruction usually eliminates the
ability to get uh often eliminates the
ability to get a uh mography a mography
you have to go for an go for an MRI at
that point
uh and having had a sister that's had it
twice uh I don't know I feel bad about
cutting that out afterwards you know not
making it free because she waited 10
years before she did anything and then
it became a very big deal because she
didn't have the money to get the
MRI
so okay I agree with you I I think we
need to do it it's buy now or pay later
so when you redo this fiscal note are
you calculating the free the the that
this would be forever ever for any
patient that once once they've been
diagnosed with cancer that that if they
I I think there's a little bit of a
misunderstanding about the preventative
Services preventative Services are meant
to help screen patients that would
otherwise not be screened to catch
Things Early once you have cancer you're
at a different level we're not doing
these preventative screenings to make
sure you're getting it caught early
you're like you said you're once cancer
patient there's a different level a
different standard of care that's
applied to you so when we do our fiscal
note analysis what we're going to be
looking at is how much for these
specific Imaging that's mentioned in
this bill which is specific to breast
cancer so we're talking Diagnostic and
supplemental breast screenings of those
that are subject to cost sharing how
much cost sharing is being paid by the
patient because that is what's going to
be shifted to the insurers now having to
take on that complete responsibility and
that is what we'll be doing the analysis
on to see how much of an impact that is
and that and that would assume forever
right that that patient was going to
have to have that more expensive MRI
every year we would have to do
much much bigger modeling for that
because what we're looking at is claims
data for a year assuming you know
there's so many women getting these
screenings right in one year say there's
you know a thousand of them how many of
that thousand are doing the diagnostic
and um preventative that's how we would
be modeling it if you want to do more an
Actuarial analysis of the overall risk
and how that we would have to do some
kind of mandate study for that the
Mandate study so um because the issue is
so you're you're saying we're you're
just going to look at the just the cost
sharing for cost sharing Services
getting an MRI in one
year and so theoretically that that
should pick up the people who are
getting have been getting it multiple
years in past years yes if they had one
in the last year I think there's there's
some other aspects to this that you
don't really want to gloss over because
the amount of cost sharing you have to
pay is highly dependent on the type of
plan you have if you have a platinum
level plan the amount you're going to
have to pay is a lot less than someone
in a bronze level plan right so that's a
huge factor in this is there's a lot of
different plans out there and the amount
of cost sharing you're going to have to
pay for not just this but all your
services is going to depend a lot on
that plan so if you were in a bronze
plan and you find out you have cancer
the next year you move up to a platinum
because you know you're going to have a
lot of Health cost that's not going to
be captured in the analysis that we're
doing so there there's a lot of other
factors that go into this we're strictly
looking at the cost shifting of the cost
sharing to the
insurers yeah so we don't know how much
adverse selection is is this with this
mandate would would cost CA this man
this mate could cause if you want to
look at more longterm and some of these
other issues that we're talking about it
would have to be a different type of
study that we be pretty complicated to
figure out so we would need a lot more
time to do something like that then we'd
have to do a mandate study yeah
something like it's it's not really a
mandate because it would be just a cost
sharing but um we're talking about a lot
of different issues being thrown out
here so if we wanted us to do some kind
of study about that we'd have to have
you know clearly defined what you're
looking for if we're talking about
long-term effects of you know out of
pocket for cancer patients and what that
means for them that's a much different
study than doing a fiscal note for this
bill okay all right so you you'll have
that fiscal note yes we'll try to get it
over to OS today great all right so
we'll put this off to unless anybody
else has anything else they want to
offer up we'll put this off to some
other
time
okay
c yeah we yeah um Katherine yeah yeah so
so this is just a subcommittee you know
I want to clarify I hope as theor
clarify just two points sure yes but
yeah in general when a subcommittee you
don't put a pin card you got got I
appreciate that I don't have this in
transportation so I'm not as familiar
thank you I just wanted um as a prime
sponsor of the bill there were two
points I wanted to make I know the
concern about the slippery slope it's
difficult to talk about who should
entitled to coverage for different
conditions but um I wanted to reiterate
from the initial hearing that we have
the fourth highest rate of breast cancer
in the country um it is incredibly
prevalent and yet only about 16% of
patients need to have this diagnostic or
supplemental Imaging so there's say that
again how many about 16% after their
mammograms need to go on to have the
supplemental Diagnostic Imaging so while
there is a lot of reason to to catch
early it's actually a smaller number of
people needing that followup so that
limits the cost and I also just wanted
to mention in terms of the continued
diagnostic testing after you've had
cancer um I think it's about 5 to 10
years that you would need that sort of
um skipping over the mamogram and going
to the diagnostic imaging it's not
forever okay but it's two confusing you
gave two stats there they were they
actually are confusing to me because you
say okay we we're the fourth in the
country that would means we have a lot
of people who have breast cancer then
you said but only 16 would need to go on
to get this MRI I realize that they
opposing my my point being it's it is
this is a very common cancer right so
when we're talking about how do we I
guess way what sort of uh procedures or
testing and among different conditions
or different cancers we want to be
considering this is something that's
really really common in New Hampshire
that being said it's still a small
subsect people that need to go on for
this extra level of imag or supplement
so it does limit the cost in that regard
and that would be another 5 to 10 years
and then it would be 5 to 10 years until
they're out of the woods that is my
understanding yes okay great thank you
yes thank you any other okay great
thanks all right let's move on to the
next
one uh no that was what we just
did okay
12:25 prescription Doug affordability
Board of conflict
interests
okay
so
um we found that I guess my researchers
found I just got a something from her
today she said that this a conflict of
interest and who has a conflict is is
all over the board in terms of who does
for different boards there are different
rules and regulations already but she
said no one has it where just one board
member has that decision even though
this the attorney general the way the
appointee do I have this right do I have
Bill are you asking a question yes I'm
asking you a question this is a
subcommittee
speak uh hi I I'm representative Jess
Edwards and um the original Bill uh
identified a problem that uh in the
prescription drug affordability board
act it it conflicts of interest were
prohibited but there were no Provisions
for what to do once a conflict was
identified and and how to go about uh
removing somebody with a conflict of
interest so the the bill as
introduced attempted to begin that
conversation and and provided uh a a way
of doing it um and you're referring to
an amendment and I'm I'm I'm less
familiar with the amendment the
amendment may have been offered by
representative Merchant um and uh and
and it and that's why I came to the
subcommittee today to listen to your
discussion because I'm less interested
in um
how uh the the tactics of of working
through the conflict of interest I just
assume follow whatever standard
approaches the state might use um I I I
what I'm really concerned about is that
there is no there is no provision for
removing somebody with a conflict of
interest and and that's a a flaw in the
bill and I suppose I could have done
better homework before presenting it to
the committee but I I believe that this
committee with the jurisdiction would
would have some wisdom about the other
ways in which we handle such a problem
and
so I I I I threw it over the transom Mr
chair I gotcha okay so uh if you were
compare to our conflict of
interests I believe that all we're supp
it's up to us
individually to uh make notification to
everybody that we have a conflict but
that in that form we can check off and
say but we're still going to participate
or we're not but at least we made the
disclosure to everybody that there is a
a perception that they might have a
interest
yeah we could we could do it that way I
I would choose to to to to go more on
offense because this board is very small
it it it's only got like five people
with some alternates and this board has
tremendous power to demand from the
market uh very specific ific proprietary
information that has high commercial
value and and because I think the threat
from somebody who's unethical being on
this board is significantly larger than
having one of 400 of us running around
uh I I would I would want there to be um
a more difficult standard for that
individual remaining on the board I I
would want a way to to remove them okay
so if I read this bill your bill
correctly it's the governor and Council
removes removes the person is that is
that correct yes I I I thought that
there should be some Authority and I
didn't know where to put it and if U if
the committee sees um a a better way of
doing it I I'm I'm I am fully in support
of the smartest way to do this I just
don't want to go naked
with this much uh commercial
value potentially
exposed
okay fair enough any questions to the
committee representative
Gibbs thank you um I'm certainly not
speaking in favor of conflict of
interest but I'm just curious and my
apologies if this was covered during the
uh public hearing uh because I actually
don't remember whether it was or not um
do you have any reason to believe that
there is a problem of conflict of
interest uh with the uh prescription
drug affordability
board I I I'd say in general whenever
you allow people access to very high
value
data uh it is wise to assume that there
will be people who will abuse that trust
and that you should anticipate rational
ways of removing the threat so that the
uh the security of the data uh and the
Integrity of the board is preserved so
uh so I I would I would I'm not saying
that there's anyone now on the board but
given that this is a brand new board and
it got set up rapidly and prematurely I
think I we we left some things out and
so this is one of the things that I
think we left out that we should put
back
in well you didn't leave it out it's
actually in statute right now there is a
conflict of interest process in the in
the current law ye yes sir but there's
no removal process and so what this bill
intends to do is to create a a
methodology to remove somebody that has
a conflict of interest it's it's one
thing to say you have a conflict of
interest it's another thing to say you
have a conflict of interest and you can
no longer serve on the board and have
access to highly confidential valuable
commercial
information so if I read the current law
it it's basically what we do for
ourselves you you identify that you have
a conflict in the public me in five day
period advance of the meeting you're
supposed to announce that you have a
conflict but there's no take you want to
process to get them
off
I again to protect the Integrity of the
board and te the protect the Integrity
of the expensive information of the held
by private citizens I think yes we we
need to be able to be proactive okay
okay yes represent
Ammon you go
ahead thank you um I'm not on the
subcommittee but I I do have a question
representative Edwards uh how would the
process work with the governor and the
council do they would they take make a
motion take a vote and it would be a
six-way vote to remove someone how do
you foresee that procedure playing
out I I did not thank you for the
question I didn't I didn't get very deep
deep into how the procedure would work I
put put an approach in the bill and I'm
open to how it could be done and if for
some reason uh the sub committee decides
not to try to fix this bill and isn't
happy with the bill as is
is I I will regret that I didn't put
more time into it before it came to the
committee and work on it in the future
committee okay represent uh represent m
c is next uh thank you uh I'm I'm really
curious who would who would appoint this
board and and what kind of people would
be would make make up the the the
committee the the prescription drug
affordability board is already in
statute and the methods of who appoints
which member is is already in statute th
what this is saying is in the in the
bill there is a provision saying that
there shall not be conflicts of interest
amongst the board
members what the bill before you intends
to do is to create a mechanism to remove
an appointed board member member who has
been identified as having a conflict of
interest so this is this is there the
the the bill is the law is silent on on
the removal aspect no I understand that
but I'm assuming you're referring to
things like insider trading is that
correct that could be an example or it
could be somebody who just has some
other uh vested interest or or opens up
a side shop on Consulting because this
information is extremely valuable and
and could make somebody a lot of money
field forell thank you so who has
jurisdiction over this board so who
initially appoints and then I I'm sorry
I keep thinking org charts but we don't
have one here so who ultimately does
this board um respond
to and who has jurisdiction who the
appointments are made the Governor
president of the Senate Speaker of the
House appoint they appoint but they
would have jurisdiction over this board
so would they be the appropriate
mechanism for removal so so one of the
weaknesses of of of the initial Statute
in my view and to your point is is that
this board is highly autonomous once it
gets going it it's highly autonomous it
really reports to no one for example
even though it's Bud it has to have
accountability to somebody well I'm
going to try to explain some of that so
so so to the extent even that it has a
budget uh the budget goes through the
commissioner of
DHHS but but he or she does not have the
authority to change the budget it's just
simply an
administrative transmission of the
request of the board for it to go to
into the budget cycle and and prior to
hb2 the uh uh the the finance committee
didn't even have an opportunity to take
care of the budget so so this board once
it's established and it has already been
established and been running for a while
it it runs very much on its own and
anytime you I I I don't know I'm just a
cynic I I think that if you have too
much power Consolidated in a very small
group and you have no checks and
balances on it you run the risk of abuse
and and so one way to reign in the abuse
in my view is if there is a conflict of
interest have a mechanism to swap that
individual out because the board is very
independent okay representative Gibbs
thank you um yes am I correct uh
representative Edwards um that you
sponsored a bill last year to to um uh
abolish the prescription drug
affordability
board I I I submitted two bills one of
them abolished it and one of it amended
the uh the board
significantly and I provided the option
to this committee for debate and
discussion so you debated two of my
bills one was to improve and fix the
problems that I identified in the board
and one was simply to abolish it so I I
I should add that I'm now a member of
the board I I was appointed in August to
this board and so at least now I have an
Insider view of the the the the power
and role of the board a follow up to
what you um just mentioned earlier about
the budget uh so the board now has a
budget uh which will be uh in the
biannual budget uh every other year and
therefore the budget would be controlled
by the finance committee so in that
sense um the board is accountable to the
finance committee and ultimately uh to
Senate more so than it was and I I have
to actually go back and double check
with my uh budget assistant I I don't
know if the provisions of hb1 or hb2
rather were constructed for this budget
cycle and then expires or whether it's
got
the the the the continuing nature of law
so I I I should be able to answer your
question better but I don't know the
hb2 okay
um so yeah representative po sorry um
sorry this is just a clarification so we
did have rep mer Merchants um Amendment
but we're not looking at that we're
still looking at the original Bill we're
still talking about the original Bill
thank
you
um
so people feel they have a vision here
anybody feel one way or the other what
they want to do about this or we could
put it off and think about this for
another
week I don't think we have an answer yet
we don't have an answer okay let's we'll
put this one
off yes representative Amon has a
question thank you uh just a question so
the amendment that we we haven't
considered uh puts the opice on the
Attorney General to determine what a
conflict of interest is uh it also
removes the cohabitation language that's
in the earlier part of the bill removing
the cohabitation language is just fine
with me I I I it bugs me that married
people get hit with this and the co
cohabitors don't don't but you can
strike all the cohabitant I don't I
don't I don't think placing all of this
at the AG's office is is the right way
to do it that was uh representative
Merchant he chairs the board um right
and that's and like I said U no nobody
else has ever done that before so but it
goes back to the way the statute's
written now is the same conflict of
interest that we all abide by which is
disclosure so so I'd be happy if their
subcommittee meets again to i' be happy
to participate okay great yes represent
um just want thank you for taking the
question would a CA somebody who gets
financial support from like a
pharmaceutical industry too when they
run for office would that be a conflict
commission I'm outside of my subject
matter expertise and so I'll just
disclose that on personal level I would
consider that a conflict of interest and
I would personally disclose it but I'm a
highly ethical
individual I I would think that if you
yeah if you were you were getting a
check from a pharmaceutical company you
would have to claim that make everybody
know right okay great thanks all right
how we doing for time
okay so um for I just realized that I
had property and casually down here at
the
bottom that I I we're not going to get
to you guys so
so I'm sorry you're here but but uh but
that this is not going to happen today I
don't think okay
uh what's
that that would be great you could show
me off off like we're not going to take
it up again today okay today is not
today we're going
to then forward that to me yeah yes
please yes forward it to me so what you
have is a check that didn't have the
ambulance company on it and what
insurance company was that Anthem was
Anthem okay do you want to talk about
that at all anymore no okay I don't I
just wanted it I want to send you send
that to all just type in house Commerce
and get it all to us so we all can see
it okay Mr chairman I I have a question
why we have representative PR here
though if you don't mind why is he here
no I have a question while he's still
here oh relative to that if you mind you
can go ask him out in the hall no well
it's for the okay I I we're not in that
subcommittee right now no I'm I'm
not this is not a free-for-all okay next
up actually this is the last one I think
we're going to take up because I guess
this is now turned into a problem all
right 1365 substitution of biological
products by pharmacies so we have have
somebody here from the industry who will
this um yeah I I think I think I think
this will be our last one for this
morning because it's almost noon
so
glucose all right go ahead good morning
Mr chairman U members of the actually
you know what are you locally are you
local or where are you from uh just
outside of Boston okay so it's not local
okay go ahead uh well thank you Mr
chairman thank you members of the
committee uh for allowing me to be here
today um I I work on behalf of Amgen uh
we're in opposition to House Bill 1365
which looks to expand upon the
biosimilar substitution statute found
within the pharmacy Practice Act that
was passed and signed uh into law back
in
2018 um I work as part of Amgen state
government Affairs team covering New
England um as background Amgen is a
biotechnology company backed by 40 years
of experience in the research devel Vel
m in manufacturing of Innovator and
biosimilar uh biologic medicines uh amen
is a a a global leader in biosimilar
development with five biosimilars and
one of our our biosimilars is designated
to be interchangeable um as part of our
portfolio and more biosimilars currently
in
development Amgen does not believe this
proposed change to the New Hampshire
pharmacy Practice Act is appropriate for
legal and scientific
reasons um before um I get into the
reasons why we're opposed to the
legislation I thought I would just take
a quick minute kind of like a one-on-one
to just to talk about um the differences
between
um uh biosimilars and interchangeable
biosimilars and kind of what the
designation is and and to talk about the
differences if the committee will allow
uh biosimilars are a biologic medicines
that are highly similar to and have no
clinical difference from Brand
originator biologic medicines biosimilar
can also provide lower cost treatment
options for patients um and the um you
can look for data and trends that uh
biosimilar utilization is uh
significantly increasing which is
helping drive down patient cost for
these specialty
medicines um but it's also important to
note that biosimilars are more complex
than generic drugs and are subject to
different legal requirements so uh
biologics and small molec ules which are
pills um generics completely different
totally apples to oranges uh biologics
are
injectables um and the the manufacturing
has to be so precise on all these
biologics that patients are putting into
their bodies um it's completely
different than with a pill where you
follow a certain
recipe and that can be done 100% of the
time for all of these
generics an interchangeable biosimilar
is a biosimilar that the FDA has
determined meets additional criteria
that manufacturers have to
undergo so that it may be substituted
for its brand reference product at the
pharmacy interchangeability is regulated
under federal law and is a special
designation made by the FDA after
scientific and Technical
assessments these involve additional
extensive testing that can take a
manufacturers have to provide additional
investment in time um so that the FDA
can undergo this this really extensive
testing to ensure that the
interchangeable is 100% exactly the same
as the originator
product most biologics dispensed at the
pharmacy are injectable products such as
injectable pens that are
self-administered by patients or by
caregivers when assessing
interchangeability FDA May evaluate
potential differ in product
characteristics such as differences in
dosing or delivery devices to help avoid
Administration errors misdosing and
other errors that a patient or caregiver
might have when administering one of
these
biologics it's important to understand
that FDA assesses only whether a
biosimilar is interchangeable with its
brand reference product and one of the
most important kind of keys to this is
the FDA does not evaluate
whether one biosimilar is
interchangeable with any other
biosimilar in other words FDA does not
assess potential differences between one
interchangeable biosimilar and another
interchangeable biosimilar even though
FDA has determined that both products
are interchangeable with the same brand
reference product so you can kind of go
and you can look for clinical trials you
can look for data you can look for
research and you won't find anything
because this is not legal within FDA to
substitute one interchangeable for
another it's never been done before so
um this really harms potentially harms
patients if passed because a patient
would be putting something into their
body that um has never been evaluated
from a scientific
standpoint Pharmacy substitution
practices are regulated under state law
the pharmacy substitution laws in all 50
States including New Hampshire permit a
pharmacist to dispense an inter
interchangeable biosimilar only when the
brand reference product has been
prescribed and believed the current
biosimilar substitution statute we
believe that the current biosimilar
statute is working well for patients
here in the state and in the other 49
states as
well with all of that in mind I just
wanted to kind of talk about some of the
merits why we are in opposition to this
bill we believe that the bill would
undermine physician choice and disrupt
patient care the bill ignores the fda's
fundamental role in assessing products
for safe Pharmacy
substitution the bill would declare
interchangeable bio similars that share
reference product as interchangeable
with each other even though the FDA
hasn't evaluated whether it would be
appropriate for a pharmacy to dispense a
sub substituted product when a physician
has prescribed a specific
interchangeable
biosimilar already under existing New
Hampshire law when a physician
prescribes a brand reference product a
pharmacy may substitute any biosimilar
that FDA has determined is
interchangeable with that referenced
product so pharmacists already can
substitute an available interchangeable
biosimilar when a patient has been
prescribed a brand reference product can
I can I stop you right there I'm
confused has the FDA determined what's
biosimilar or
not yes so the FDA goes through testing
and they they can evaluate and say yes
this is a bio similar which is highly
similar right but then there's
additional testing for interchangeable
designation that a manufacturer needs to
additional investment additional time
for the FDA to go through and do
extensive testing to receive a special
interchangeable designation and they
have or they have not done that yet yes
that's that has taken place so all we
have to do is make sure it's been
approved by the FDA is interchangeable
bio similar that expression that that
would make you okay with this bill
no um so and I'm I'm getting there um
but but basically you know a a
physician um May prescribe a specific
interchangeable biosa for a reason they
want their patient to receive the actual
product often the prescribed products uh
might be under a preferred patients
insurance plan the physician May
prescribe it by name since the product
will result in a lower cost for the
patient or the product won't require PR
prior authorization or other
administrative hurdles so if we require
that the doctor has to now when he
writes the prescription have some kind
of code next to it like the generics did
so they can say that it can be
interchangeable if it's approved by the
FDA uh yes but one interchangeable for
the other interchangeable it it's it's
it can't happen legally because there's
no studies that have been conducted you
say legally no there's no illegal right
the FDA is not shutting it down in your
mind it's not legal but in terms it's
also not Physicians all tell us they
tell me that they want this
bill okay they want it the board of
Minister wants it the insurance
companies want it the only person in
this room who doesn't want this bill is
you and I'm trying to understand sure
but the role of the FDA the the goal of
the the FDA is to ensure patient safety
right so if the FDA says it's okay it
doesn't the FDA says this is not okay if
the FD so okay the FDA is I haven't
heard from them yet so but directly but
um all right I'm totally confused but
all
right and and also you know Physicians
have the the opportunity to write
dispenses written on the prescription so
the pharmacist has no choice uh to
substitute but this bill if passed would
make New Hampshire a complete outlier
this is one bill introduced in one state
and this would totally make New
Hampshire an outlier I think this would
cause uh confusion with Physicians so a
physician might prescribe an
interchangeable biologic to a patient
and all of a sudden this gets changed to
another interchangeable if the the
doctor was not aware um of this law you
know there are different um delivery
mechanisms as well so just because one
interchangeable is another
interchangeable means the delivery might
not be exactly the same and the
physician might not know that
speaking don't he's speaking oh ask
please my goal was to be
brief so does the committee do we want
to maybe just inter room study this bill
since this is evidently not ready for
prime
time okay does anybody have a problem
with inter room study yeah what I'm
asking a question now is everybody okay
with inter room study the
bill okay I well I represent him M's
first you want to he's El set
representative Speer and looking at this
bill when it first came out I did a bit
of looking around and Europe does this
extensively I found all kinds of
approvals for this kind of thing all
throughout Europe so this is not
really you know a pie in the sky brand
new nobody's ever looked at it before
kind of thing we may be behind the time
I mean that's typical in some areas but
this isn't really new and that Europe
has been doing it for a while and
getting some pretty darn good results so
I I think saying that we're taking all
these risks and everything has been
proven in a very large platform to not
quite be the case which is why we should
go to inrim study now that which is fine
so are you have you been looking at any
of that before we say that this is such
a high risk well I'm just going off
guidance from FDA and you know we
obviously patient safety is number one
and you know what FDA says is is what we
have to go
by
thank you for the
question but you did take FDA as as okay
for the the P Bill I said the FDA has
Pierce uh thank you Mr chairman um to
simplify this in the previous
presentation the way I understood it is
that a a drug company comes up with drug
a and then another company comes up with
these are not drugs these are well part
bio specific bio yes a bio medicine I
understand and second company comes up
with b and they find out that uh B is is
interchangeable with a then a third
company comes up with c and
currently C is interchangeable with a
but not with B this law would make a b
and c all interchangeable correct this
so it make b equals c right so that you
so that if B was prescribed you could
use a or C okay well you'd want to go to
C most likely we we have the chart
that's what I I just want to clarify
okay yes go ahead it's not about the
chart okay
r hi I just have a question do you think
this is a leg State Legislative issue uh
no I believe this is more of a federal
issue okay thank you okay any more
questions is are you still yeah just I
mean I certainly support the idea of
studying it because the MDR that
representative spear brought up were
totally different but Europe's Med
device regulations and those regulations
so there might be something to be
learned from there uh my my question uh
to Mr Kent is on the form factor issue
so that's what comes to mind to me how
how big of an impact is that when
talking about one interchangeable or
bial similar to another in other words
could I get be expecting or have a
patient that needs an auto injector that
you know fires in and then pulls out
right you know that that type of design
and actually end up with a syringe like
a Victoza kind of pen that you have to
dial up and put a needle on I mean could
are the form factors potentially that
different my question track here well
are the form factors that different is
that an impact is that one issue yeah I
mean especially if a a patient isn't
educated on how to use it um if I'm
following you
correctly
long question but anyways I certainly
support studying the issue great all
right so would like to make the motion
represent buroughs you want to make the
okay we all do that just to see if
everybody's paying attention
right okay all right representative
burough second by representative M's
interim study is there any discussion on
the motion of in room
study ma second oh maer second sorry
okay um all those in favor raise your
hand one two three four five six six zip
okay thank you for your time thank sorry
we can't help you better
but okay
1571 requiring insurance coverage for
glucose monitoring devices for people
with diabetes
this sounds like a mandate
too
just just
kill killing me
okay
um all right
so how how did we we left this bill was
this this was a bill wasn't this one
that we needed a study the financial
study
on interim the um well we need the
Mandate study as we call it I call it
the Murphy law but
but the Mandate study this one does have
a fiscal note we did complete the fiscal
note but you're correct that it was it's
expanding the scope of the benefit right
so if you would like to do a mandate
study we could do that if um if we would
just need the formal request from the
committee to the department that you're
requesting um a mandate study and if if
you do do that it's good to be as
specific as possible as to what exactly
you're looking for if you want us to
study this bill as written or with um
certain amendments or changes or
note no there's a from what I printed
out the small or this morning or last
night there's definitely a FIS on we did
prepare one and I believe this is
printed from so what I'm looking I'm
looking at the back page is this verbage
I there's the chart and then there's
like a page and a half of okay
information okay so you want to walk us
through here and show us what where
where where's it I don't see any dollars
here it's
indeterminable right no we got that we
all we all have that okay but it was
just there was zeros sure so no I don't
can
I so it's in your fiscal no is in
terminal is it where where's money where
money so it's in terminal it will
increase but we don't know we'd have to
do a mandate study to give you a rough
all
right there it goes into more detail
explaining that's so that's all I
remember when when we ended up was that
we didn't have any idea what we were
talking
about yes so if you want us to do a
mandate study for the bill as written um
we can do that we would just need you to
formally ask us to do that and specify
what exactly you want us to study is it
the bill as written or are there very
iations of it that you would like us to
with all right but but at the end of the
day we're the end of day we're trying to
model it off of the the
diabetes stat statute we already have
now which is a
$30 so there's different aspects to this
so the statute we have now limits cost
sharing limits to cost sharing do not
require defray I believe what this bill
is trying to do is mandate coverage of
these glucose monitoring devices for
type one and type two and gestational
diabetes and I think it's my
understanding and my expert left because
he said he weren't going to take this up
my understanding is these devices are
already covered routinely for type one
diabetes Tye their utility for type two
and gational diabetes I think is a
little bit more gray so those would not
typically be covered for treatment of
those conditions
so what we could do if we were going to
do a mandate study is look at what the
clinical criteria are for using the
these devices based on the Medical
Science as it is now whether it would be
appropriate to do that or not and then
if there is a utilization for this we
could also look at estimates about what
this would cost to um to provide these
devices to this expanded population do
we know how much these things cost it
depends on the device and I unless it's
in the fiscal not no I do not know off
the top of my head but there's different
cost associated with it too it's the
device itself and then there's different
parts of the device stri that have to
get um strips and not NE I think these
are the implantable ones these oh parts
and again I'm not an expert on this
device these ones you have your phone
you can yeah but there's different
things that you have to replace in them
and I think depending on the device
there's different costs associated with
the different things that need to be
replaced and I think some of them you
have to replace certain things like
every two weeks some of them are I and I
don't know the details with that that we
would need a mandate study to do a
survey of what devices are available the
costs associated with them and then the
costs associated with expanding it to
this um population that under current um
right polic you're saying type one is
covered now yes okay because that's
that's the one that's most critical I
think but you guys what do you guys
think about I think a mandate study
mandate study okay
great so you'd have to vote on that yes
done that I know I have to send a letter
to Alex official Thing official letter
saying but we'll have in it the
parameters that we want to do so um yeah
so if you could give me a rough draft
which you think is probably the right
questions to ask I will work on that you
could do that for me that'd be great
send that to me and then we'll we'll
take this up again some other time okay
once we have that okay sounds good all
right so once we have a letter once we
have what we're going to be asking what
we're thinking about then we can take
action on this bill that make sense y
okay it's noon it's time time to go
go
big
so so I
[Laughter]
uh the the Democrats decided to give me
the Valentine President says cutie pie
Democrats I would be very surprised if
you would give me a
right okay uh sorry about the delay but
uh we now have uh the final Amendment
from represent L and
uh so uh I'm going to start right in
with say we'll take a motion from
representative buroughs who will move
ought to pass on the
amendment okay um I would like second in
by we don't know what's in here
discussion okay we're just we're just
passing the amendment because then I was
going to ask representative lean to tell
us what's changed but I thought we start
with a motion okay I'd like to P I'd
like to move o OTP on the amendment o 6
okay we have representative SEC wait did
I get the number right you're right
okay
okay multiple multiple seconds multiple
seconds okay repres I want you uh tell
at thank you Mr chairman and members of
the committee this is almost exactly the
same as what was done yesterday in the
subcommittee except for two changes on
page one lines 25 and 27 um it now reads
that many years of work have led to this
effort which addresses the following
goals to put the state of New Hampshire
in the driver's seat to focus on harm
reduction not profits and it had uh
cited a memo from the governor
previously and uh that was an oversight
on my mind I really shouldn't be naming
anybody within the purpose and intent so
I removed that um so I figured that that
was probably a very good cleanup there
the other is um when I was shifting on
page 33 lines 5 through 11 replace the
previous lines I think 6 through 17 um
so as I was Shifting the money away from
pensions because I was trying to match
this to what it past Ways and Means
before and the stated preference of many
not to have any money go to Pension
funds all the other versions that I saw
sent at least 15% so I had retained that
which really was an oversight the idea
of not entangling any other federal
agencies into cannabis within New
Hampshire is a good argument to not have
the pensions receiving any money and
there's a lot of reticence from people
to have their Pension funds paid by
cannabis funds so that 15% that had
previously been going to the Pension
funds is now added added to the
education trust funds I know our schools
need it and our kids need it so um
hopefully that change is acceptable
otherwise everything else is exactly the
same as was presented to the
subcommittee
yesterday great thank you uh do we have
any questions from the committee members
yes the education uh trust fund um I
sort of have a problem with that because
of the voucher program how can we ensure
that this is going to go to public
schools and not just to the voucher
program can you is this out of line or
um so all it does is it goes to the
adequate education grant that is
available to to every student that
enrolls in a public school and now it's
to those children who are seeking
education elsewhere um you know that I
think is is one of these more policy
decisions that we have you know where
else do we send it do we send it to the
general fund for it to go somewhere else
um with it offsetting swept you know I
think we can have those ongoing
discussions about whether um students
who aren't in a public school should be
means tested whether students in public
schools itself should be means tested so
that we're not paying for millionaires
to go to the public schools but I think
think that's sort of outside of the
scope of this um given that we're going
to have to be spending a lot more money
on education going forward it seems a
prudent place I'd be happy to amend it
to the general fund if you prefer that
but to me it seems the best
choice yeah I would say that uh a
constituent constituent of mine um this
morning after commenting about our being
on mu last night uh also mentioned that
uh as long as that money goes to reduce
taxes then it's a good thing and clearly
putting it in the trust fund will help
be directed back to our property taxes
yes and with that there is the note that
it specifically reduces the swept so
that that will go directly to property
taxpayers with all of that money
directly to their tax
bills okay any other discussion on the
motion about to pass on the amendment
those are the only two changes those are
changes see being none uh the clerk will
call the
role this is aop pass as
amended and you might want to turn your
mic
on yep thank
you representative Ammon
yes
uh
grassy
yes
pusk
yes post no yes yes uh Tuda
yes
belli
no
baxton yes Walsh
no Burrows yes Herbert yes cler yes maer
yes representative B
Balden
yes representative collabo
who's
migu on the amendment yes
okay
yep uh representative
Gibbs
yes
spear yes
Sullivan and chairman
hunt yes so who do we oh okay so Terry
Terry oh I didn't even see him there how
you miss I don't know he snuck in uh
yes great so 182
18-2 the motion now is ought to pass as
motion see none the clerk will call the
role
okay oh excuse me representative burough
second by representative pusc um do I
need to do it or do I need to say it no
I already did it okay do you mean you
right right ought to pass as
yes representative
pusk
yes wait a minute oh
mchu no well no I have Osborne twice
Osborne should be terrible right happy
to vote twice oh Osborne was on the
sheep yes where did you find that sheep
gave it
is hang on where is
a no so that's a no all right so that
I'll change that M
you all right uh representative post
yes uh tutor
yes pachelli
no
Axton
yes
Walsh
no Burrows yes
Herbert
yes
Balden
yes collabro yes grassie
yes Gibbs
yes spear
yes
Sullivan and chairman hunt yes yes right
okay 17
to3 and would I assume there would be a
Minority
Report okay representative walls okay so
the motion passes vote 17 to three and
calendar all right we all
set
that
was that
charm